Chris Sims pro football live co-host
with Mike Florio bleacher report NFL
analyst and the former NFL quarterback
hi Chris hey what's up Dan how you doing
man I'm ready - you always have opinions
but I'm curious what you think of this
ESPN list where they were ranking these
quarterbacks but you had comments from
scouts and defensive coordinators
coaches on this some pretty pretty
brutal some honest comments here about
these quarterbacks did any of them stand
out to you well III can't say you know
I'm gonna sit here and dissect every
comment that I see on here I think the
thing that I look at more than anything
you know first of all it's just where
I'd argue some of the points here okay
like let's just start there I look at
like tier 1 tier 1 Rodgers Brady
no-brainer
right like that's yeah there's no doubt
about it but where I would push back is
like three four and five now I know
where tier two is five with Matt Ryan
but where I see Drew Brees at three Ben
Roethlisberger for Matt Ryan at five I
would substitute those three four or
five with Russell Wilson Matthew
Stafford and Carson Wentz to me at this
point in his career for Drew Brees or
Ben Roethlisberger I don't think they're
the level of player that a Russell
Wilson or a Stafford is and of course
Carson Wentz was the MVP of football
last year in my eyes if he doesn't get
hurt you know they're in week 15
all right so Brady and Rodgers heads
above everybody else even Brady at his
age which is pretty remarkable yeah I
mean Brady Brady certainly is a tier 1
quarterback now I do think there's a
significant gap between Aaron Rodgers
and everybody else and you know I have a
love affair with Aaron Rodgers whatever
it may be but I also think you know that
I try to evaluate these things and try
to be as unbiased as possible or
unbiased as possible Aaron Rodgers
deserves to be in like tier zero right
now I mean we're talking about the
greatest gunslinger we've ever seen in a
sport yet he protects the ball better
than anybody we've ever seen in the
sport very horrible offense like I
always told you about Aaron Rodgers the
Green Bay Packers it is all about him
and his ability to make magic happen is
the only way they can win football games
so that's where I separate them and
then the other one that I don't
understand the I don't want to say
disrespect but Matthew Stafford at
number seven to me is a little
disrespectful at this point of his
career you know I get sick of hearing
the whole you know oh he didn't win he
hasn't won playoff games okay I mean
tell me some players he's had on his
team worth a damn other than Calvin
Johnson through his career I mean Tom
Brady in New England isn't doing it all
by himself he's had a lot of Hall of
Famers on both sides of the ball to help
him in it and the greatest coach in the
history of all time so you need some
help Matt Stafford is a guy look at the
go one of the most physically gifted
court best gifted quarterbacks ever to
play the game one of the greatest arms
to ever play the game he is the only
reason the Detroit Lions are relevant in
this situation offensive line play as
you know has been horrible
I don't think they've had a hundred yard
rusher in a football game since 2013 and
don't think they've had a thousand yard
rusher since he's been there so you know
we look at Matthew Stafford and go all
day you know doesn't want a playoff game
or they just missed out on the playoffs
and I want to go well those Detroit lion
teams are like four and twelve football
teams without Matthew Stafford he makes
them relevant and puts them in the
conversation for the playoffs and being
a playoff caliber team yeah I think
Roethlisberger's too high I could see
where the Saints had become a running
team a run first pass second so I would
I would drop Brees down Russell Wilson
deserves to be higher up I don't think
anybody was more valuable to their team
than he was last year and so I would put
him in that category as well
McLovin run down the rest of the list
there so we got it's Brady then Rodgers
yeah Brady Rodgers Brees Roethlisberger
number five is tier two Matt Ryan okay
then then you get Russell Wilson then
you have a four mention Matthew Stafford
and I just want to add that a lot of
people think Steph it's too high on this
list okay go in the opposite direction
Philip Rivers and yeah yep then you get
Carson went to nine number ten is Andrew
Luck with a lot of asterisks about his
health 11 Cam Newton number 12 is there
a car which they said was too high I
think that's that's too high for him 13
Jimmy G Ford's too high for him too
deshaun Watson 15 Kirk Cousins tied with
Alex
15:17 is Eli Manning tied with dak
Prescott all right that's good all right
then Jared Goff night Kirk Kirk deed
Cousins has done more than some of these
other quarterbacks I'm done yeah III
hear you I mean there's there's a few
things there to look at I mean you know
hey as good as I think Phillip Rivers is
I don't know if I would put him in front
of Carson Wentz or Cam Newton at this
point of his career another thing in
just a tear to that jumped out to me I
mean a healthy deshaun Watson to me he's
in the conversation around five six or
seven in that tier to not number 14
wealthy I mean I do I do I would put him
up in that category and you know and
then even diving into tier 3 like I'm
not you know people are always gonna
think I'm a hater because my dad was
still Sims and I played for the Giants
listen Eli Manning is the greatest giant
quarterback of all time I understand
that but no I do not think he's the 17th
best quarterback in football right now
nor do I think he's even close to that
so I think that's a really bad
misrepresentation I would say he's the
biggest question on the Giants roster at
this point and then you know I look at
that I look at also you know of course
Blake bortles at 26 I think he could
have been a Tier four quarterback really
in my eyes but for the most part I don't
look at it as being too wrong I do think
people look at stats too much when they
do things like this even NFL executives
just because they have a fancy business
card doesn't mean they know it all and
you know like with a guy like Drew Brees
Dan at number three jury I mean Drew
Brees we know he's an all-time great
he's a legend he's awesome he's a
first-ballot hall-of-famer but I would
also say you know in that offense
there's a lot of quarterbacks that would
put up those kind of numbers on a yearly
basis I'm not trying to take anything
away from him I'm just saying at this
point of his career I don't think he is
on the same playing field as some of the
other quarterbacks we've seen in the top
ten just with physical ability you know
they say being able to carry your team
by yourself
I don't think Drew Brees is capable of
doing that anymore and and I think last
year kind of showed that to a degree
they changed their team or running
football team because I don't think they
wanted to rely on that from Drew Brees
better father Eli Manning's father or
your father
I can't speak to Archie's fatherhood he
seems like a really good dad he does I
agree he's a pretty good argue that
point either way I think there are two
guys that you know get a little bit
under appreciated for what they did on
the football field back in their day -
yeah and that's where I always look at
Archie and I know my dad always says
that about Archie is Archie was one of
the most talented quarterbacks he ever
saw I just never had a chance because he
never had a team around him yeah would
you rather have golf or Garoppolo I
would rather have Garoppolo at this
point I would Jared Goff I still have
questions about Jared Goff would be
another guy you know I think he's right
around that 19 or 20 range but I know
again we're in the fantasy era where
everything's about stats and quarterback
rating and that's all that people look
at I think that at least half the league
would have thrown 28 interception 28
touchdowns and seven interceptions
playing quarterback for that Rams team
with Shaun mcveigh's offense so I don't
always look at stats and go oh yeah
that's a great year no it's the context
of that stats I'm not gonna give Jared
Goff a whole lot of credit when he
throws a ball behind the line of
scrimmage to Todd Gurley and he runs for
an 80 yard touchdown and go oh what a
play by Jared Goff that was unbelievable
oh it's Darden 51 or to screen to the
House by Roberts what a play by Josh
they don't say what a play by Jared Goff
they might know but that's where they
gets lost in context because after the
game people don't look Jared got played
pretty awesome and I'm not saying he
didn't play but he played a full season
though Chris Garoppolo has played seven
games I I get that I just I you know
again I'm just going off of I think pure
talent and of course what I think that
potential can be Goff is going in the
right direction I just I've always
thought Garoppolo was a little more
talented than a Jared Goff I wasn't
incredibly high on Jared Goff coming out
in the draft and I think you're gonna
see an explosion like we saw with Jared
Goff from Jimmy Garoppolo this year in
that Kyle Shanahan offense that system
fits his skill sets so well people are
gonna rank Jimmy Garoppolo higher than
he should be at the end of this year -
because his stats are going to be like
touchdown passes and eight interceptions
that really go well is he one of the
five best quarterbacks in football and I
don't care if he throws for 40
touchdowns and five interceptions he's
not one of the five best no matter what
happens at the end of the year but he is
gonna inject himself into that
conversation because people are going to
look at stats and people don't always
pay attention to context at this time
Jared golf or deshaun Watson I go to
Shawn Watson Watson has a chance to be
like if we went two to three years down
the road I wouldn't be shocked if you
and me are on the radio having a
conversation about deshaun Watson being
the best quarterback in football I think
he has that type of potential and I
think what he did with his little four
and five game run last year man that was
some Arron Roger ish type stuff I saw
out there with him making magic happen
with his legs his arms his leadership
you know all of that to where I thought
ooh that is very very special and I
think he's only scratching the surface
of what he can be I don't leave you with
this Todd Gurley got paid is TV anomaly
or our running backs now going to get
are they going to move up now the pay
scale here I do think they're gonna move
up in the pay scale I do I think with
the two running back committees that
were in the running back by committee
we're seeing throughout the NFL we're
gonna start seeing some of these
top-tier running backs you know play a
little bit longer because they're not
gonna be ground grinded into the ground
like they were in the 80s and the 90s
and the early 2000s where they had such
a short shelf life in the NFL girliest
the best running back in the sport to me
so this is where I find it interesting
is where it becomes for Le'Veon Bell now
this is really gonna dictate what he can
ask for for as well I mean you look at
girly-girly 0.7 yards per more per rush
than a levy on bail over five yards more
protection than Le'Veon Bell is equally
as important place the same type of role
except I would argue he's more explosive
than Le'Veon Bell can take the ball to
the house from 70 yards out where a levy
on Bell can't so I do think it's going
to be interesting and I think we're
seeing some serious superfreaks
at the position right
maybe more than we've ever seen thank
you Chris I hope I was good I appreciate
you having me man you the man stop by
when you you know you need to re-up
that's good oh you're funny thank you
Chris be a man to Kristen for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]